Josh Norman!
Do people in the NFL think you’re weird?
- [Clanging]
- [Sniffing] Smell it!
- What is going on?!
- [Laughing]
Yeah.
- Lefkoe here in Virginia to get a
tour of Josh Norman’s insane house.
5,400 square feet of toys, bells and
whistles, and with all that, he better have
good homeowners insurance, and I
really hope it’s with State Farm.
State Farm is sponsoring this episode, but they
also have phenomenal homeowners insurance.
I wouldn’t steer you wrong.
Let’s go ditch the playbook.
♪♪♪
Just in case you didn’t know whose house
it was—
yeah, he lets you know right in the driveway.
JNo24, Josh Norman.
One of the best cornerbacks in the league.
I gotta see what makes him the
most interesting man in the NFL.
Well, look who it is!
How you feelin’, my man?
- My man.
What’s up, Lef?
- Good to see you.
- You all right?
- You look good.
- Good to see you.
- Your house looks amazing.
- Come on, man. Come on in.
- I like the art.
I like the tone—like, the colors.
So this is the volleyball
court that I’ve heard about.
This is movie theater-level amounts of candy!
[Loud music] Wow.
I can feel it in my bones right now.
- [Laughing]
- Everybody has a pair of shoes that
kind of represents them the most.
On the wall, which ones—which
one is Josh Norman?
- Which one is me—
- Yeah.
- That represents me the
most out of these shoes.
This is it right here.
That’s why it’s out here sittin’ by itself.
- I was gonna say, it’s by itself.
- That’s why it’s by itself!
With everything else, it is by itself.
- No matter what city Josh lives in, no
matter where he goes in the world, he is
still a cowboy boot-wearin’,
horse-rearin’ country man.
- Hey, it’s through your blood and blood.
- All through your blood.
- This is my very own personal barbershop.
- Oh, you got your logo on it.
- [Laughing]
- This guy’s unbelievable.
So do you have, like, your own
private masseuse that comes over?
- Yes. I have my own private masseuse
that comes over.
I have three of ‘em actually.
- Three masseuses.
So you get your hair cut in the basement, you
get your massages upstairs—you really do not
need to leave this house.
- It’s a one-stop shop.
- There’s not a lot of NFL players
that do Dancing with the Stars.
There’s not a lot of NFL players that
have giraffes in their living room.
- Yeah, man.
- Do—I mean, do people in
the NFL think you’re weird?
- Yeah.
- Really?
- [Laughing]
- They thinkin’, like, “Something’s wrong
with this guy.” Like, “Yeah, I know he’s
interesting, but, you know,
he’s just a little bit off.”
- Little bit off.
- I gotta show you the
best room in the house.
- Really?
- Out of all the rooms, this
is the best one in the house.
- OK. Oh my God.
This is the perfect spot for your kid.
- This is the lair of the princess.
- I love the fact that there is a pony at
a table with what looks to be one of the most
incredible makeup jobs I’ve ever seen.
- You know what?
I, I’ve never seen anything better.
Never.
- [Laughing]
- What is that?!
- Come on.
- What is going on?!
- [Laughing]
- Conan the Barbarian!
- I’m a, I’m a little—
- This is like 50, 60 pounds.
- Yes.
- Bro, you’re such a nerd. I love it.
- Dude, I’m ridiculous.
- You’re a big-time nerd.
- [Laughing] Yes!
- Please tell me that you
wear that around the house.
This should be the new helmet in the NFL.
- [Clanging]
- Can you imagine if somebody tried to break
into Josh Norman’s house and he came upstairs
with a sword and a Captain America?
- It’s serious!
- I know you’re obsessed with Batman.
Like, with every morsel of your body.
So when I came in and I saw this, man, like—
- Yeah, but...
the artist who did it sucked.
- What do you mean?
- Does that look like me?!
- Oh, it was supposed to look like you?
- Yeah, supposed to.
- Oh, this was supposed to be
you in a Bat—oh, that’s not good.
- Exactly, right?!
- No, I was like—I mean—
- [Laughing] It’s like, “What is that?!”
- I wanna see your bar too.
- Oh, for sure.
Lemme show you this bar.
Take a wild guess what you think this is.
- Is that wood chips?
- This is mamajuana.
- I’mma wanna know what that is.
- Whooop.
- Oh, really?
- [Laughing]
- This is why he’s the most
interesting man in the NFL.
Every house, there’s always that thing
where they go, “And this is where the magic
happens.” But I’m not gonna do it.
- It’s fine, you can sit on the edge.
- All right.
- How does it feel?
- It feels like a very
soft, plush bed, you know?
A little chinchilla—it’s nice.
- But then when you turn
around and you turn it up...
- The bed is shaking.
- [Laughing]
- Josh, what is, what is—is this
like a massage type of thing?
- Yes.
- I don’t feel comfortable.
- [Laughing]
- Wow.
This is where the magic happens.
- [Laughing]
- Oooh.
- This is the Z28 ‘72 split
bumper Chevrolet Camaro.
- [Sighing]
- [Sniffing] Smell it!
- [Inhaling] She smells amazing.
- There’s nothin’ like old-school.
[Engine revving]
- This is Batman’s Batmobile right here.
Hope you guys enjoyed meeting the
most interesting man in the NFL.
But while we’re ditchin’ the
playbook, I gotta ditch you guys, man.
So I’mma holler atcha.
Let’s do it.
- You ready?
All right, man.
It is unreal.